y ustedes ya lo veían entonces era la
cantidad para la vicepresidencia de eeuu
o kamala harris con el actual
vicepresidente y también candidato a la
vicepresidencia
mike pence por el partido republicano
están saludando a sus respectivas
parejas la esposa del vicepresidente de
pence y el esposo de kamala harris ahí
fue entonces el primero y único debate
vicepresidencial que veremos en esta
campaña de cara a lo que van a hacer
estas elecciones generales elecciones
presidenciales en eeuu el próximo 3 de
noviembre vimos un debate en moderado en
diferencia a lo que vimos en el debate
en el primer debate presidencial en
cleveland ohio contó donald trump y
obeid en que fue un debate interrumpido
este fue un debate pausado un debate
donde los candidatos se dejaron hablar
que finalmente esa es la finalidad del
debate que los candidatos entonces
puedan expresar sus opiniones sus
argumentos y sus puntos de campaña por
supuesto el coi 19
que vivimos todos alrededor del mundo
fue el tema principal en este debate
vicepresidencial también hablaron de la
corte suprema la nominación que hizo el
presidente de donald trump miconi para
que la semana que viene entonces va a ir
al senado para que la cuestionen y vean
si al final la nombran como jueza en la
corte suprema de justicia de eeuu en
reemplazó a la fallecida
ruth báder ginsburg también hablaron
sobre el aborto y hablando de la corte
suprema de justicia de estados unidos
esto y otros temas que hoy vamos
analizar por supuesto con nuestros
invitados y nuestras corresponsales
quiero irme a washington de la capital
estadounidense con diana castañeda
empezar diana pues resaltando los puntos
o más visibles de este debate
vicepresidencial
así es vimos que como lo mencionamos el
tema de la pandemia de kobe 19 y la
respuesta de la administración del
presidente de donald trump fue el tema
central y vimos como cámara graves
comenzó atacando este manejo asegurando
pues básicamente que este es el fracaso
más grande en la historia de los eeuu
que la incompetencia del presidente don
action ha costado millones de vidas y
que también tanto trump como penses
sabían con anticipación de la naturaleza
de este virus a lo que pensó respondió
que el presidente había tomado medidas
al principio es orando los vuelos
provenientes de china y salvando vidas y
acusando a kamala harris de tratar de
socavar la confianza frente a la vacuna
otro de los temas centrales son los
escándalos en los cuales pues la prensa
ha centrado la atención frente al
presidente de unalt zombie su
declaración de impuestos
penn se defendió asegurando que el
presidente ha generado millones de
trabajos y ha pagado también millones en
impuestos otro de los temas centrales
fue la justicia racial y pence trató de
cuestionar
experiencia de kamala harris y también
porque no logro hacer cambios en el
sistema de justicia porque bajo digamos
su administración cuando se encargaba
del sistema judicial pues no esos
cambios importantes para que las
personas afroamericanas tuvieran
procesos más justos otro de los temas
centrales es si el presidente donald
trump va a reconocer estas elecciones
los resultados al final son para sembró
digamos en palabras del vicepresidente
que este será un triunfo nuevamente para
su campaña en las elecciones y lo que
básicamente dijo kamala es que se están
tratando de diferentes maneras de evitar
que los estadounidenses puedan ejercer
su derecho al voto así que digamos que
fueron estos algunos de los temas
centrales también vimos economía
acuerdos comerciales
en las relaciones con china otro de los
temas centrales pero este fue un debate
en donde se vieron más las discusiones
frente a las ideas frente a las
plataformas y ataques más ideológicos
pero donde frente a todo se conservó
digamos la decencia y estas dos
aspirantes a la vicepresidencia de los
estados unidos pudieron debatir más
ideas y no ataques como vimos en el
anterior debate presidencial así es
diana y también hubo respeto que eso es
bueno resaltarlo entre los dos
candidatos a la vicepresidencia de eeuu
quiero ir ahora con mamá en sala en la
ciudad de nueva york que mamen cómo se
vive el debate y además le pregunto cómo
estuvieron estos candidatos a la
vicepresidencia del país
sin muy buenas noches raúl pues sí que
es verdad que fue un debate mucho más
moderado en el que pudimos escuchar
ideas y las propuestas de ambos
candidatos pero también es verdad que se
dejaron de responder muchas preguntas
por parte de la moderadora que eran
bastante interesantes como qué va a
pasar si donald trump no acepta los
resultados qué va a pasar en caso de que
tanto el candidato demócrata joe biden o
el propio presidente de donald trump
tengan algún problema de salud en este
debate tenemos que tenemos que recordar
que no solamente estaban enfrentándose
dos vicepresidentes sino también dos
futuros presidentes en caso de que les
pase algo a los presidentes esta
pregunta tampoco la han contestado pensé
el vicepresidente mike pence ha dejado
claro que tampoco ha respondido el
partido demócrata no lo hizo yo o bailén
en el primer debate y no lo ha hecho
cabal a harris tampoco sobre qué va a
pasar cuál va a ser si van a desmontar
la corte suprema en caso de que salga
elegida
la candidata barre entonces al final sí
que es verdad que ha habido mucho más
respeto pero se han dejado de contestar
muchísimas preguntas ha sido un debate
en el que también la moderadora ha
tenido que pedir que se respeten esas
normas que se habían pactado previamente
interesante también que el
vicepresidente mike pence en algún
momento se ha salido del discurso que
estamos acostumbrados a escuchar al
presidente de donald trump como que por
ejemplo el virus que él se contagia era
poco menos que una bendición y que ahora
no había que temer a ese virus ni dejar
que dominará nuestra vida mike pence ha
arrancado este debate mirando a cámara y
diciendo pues lo mucho que sienten todas
las pérdidas que ha habido en eeuu
cuando ya hemos superado de los 211 mil
muertos por kobe 19 en un intento de
crear empatía con los ciudadanos
estadounidenses en dos momentos ha
contradicho al presidente uno de ellos
ha sido cuando ha hecho que la vacuna
estaría lista antes de fin de año no lo
ha contradecido pero sí que es verdad
que donald trump siempre ha apostado de
hecho lo hacía minutos antes de empezar
el debate con un vídeo a través de sus
redes sociales con que esa vacuna
estaría
antes del 1 de noviembre y por otro lado
también ha dicho que siempre estarán
siguiendo y apoyando lo que dicen los
científicos cuando ya vimos en los
incendios de california que donald tran
dijo ante los medios de comunicación que
los científicos no saben de esto y que
pronto enfriar a otra vez las
temperaturas así es mamen como ustedes
lo dijo varias preguntas sin responder
buen punto buen punto para resaltar en
este debate vicepresidencial quiero
saludar ahora en este momento a uno de
nuestros analistas invitados él es
rafael piñero profesor de relaciones
internacionales en la universidad
externado de colombia profesor
nuevamente le doy las gracias por estar
con nosotros y las buenas noches
empecemos por el punto principal de este
debate que fue la pandemia de ccoo y 19
como lo decía ya nuestra corresponsal
más de 210.000 fallecidos por esta
pandemia en eeuu 30 millones de
desempleos que ha dejado las secuelas de
esta enfermedad también más de 7
millones de contagiados el
vicepresidente y máis bng se le volvió a
echar la culpa a china por la por la
realidad que está
yendo por cuenta de esta pandemia porque
recordemos que fue en la ciudad de wuhan
donde se originó este nuevo kobe 19
porque le siguen echando la culpa a
china por el origen de esta pandemia y
además le pregunto si es posible y es
viable y qué y qué argumentos se tiene y
qué evidencia que una vacuna
estadounidense puede estar lista antes
de primero de noviembre precisamente dos
días antes de las elecciones
presidenciales
sin duda alguna la pandemia transformó
la vida de los estadounidenses durante
el 2020 y no solo en la vida económica y
social también la vida política y es un
elemento que hay que tenerlo presente si
las elecciones hubieran sido en enero o
febrero sin duda alguna de un hecho muy
gran tenía un camino mucho más fácil
para ser reelegido en ese sentido veo
bastante difícil que lo que menciona
tanto el presidente como su
vicepresidente sea cierto en este
momento no hay pruebas médicas que
certifiquen que alguno de los distintos
proyectos de alcanzar una vacuna sea
realizable al menos durante el 2020 eso
abre un espacio significativamente
amplio para seguir debatiendo sobre cómo
van a responder el punto o el asunto es
que camba la jara es tampoco fue lo
suficientemente clara más allá de
plantear unas tres una estrategia en la
cual se va a hacer un rastreo que va a
ser un monitoreo constante tampoco
mencionó que podrían hacer para alcanzar
no a una más rápida mencionó el hecho de
que
habría la posibilidad de que fuera
abierta para todos pérez es un elemento
muy bajo así que sin duda alguna la
pandemia será seguirá marcando lo que
veamos en las próximas dos semanas hubo
una respuesta de kamala harris que me
llamó mucho la atención cuando le
preguntaron que qué pasaba si se
encontraba una vacuna ella dijo si el
doctor fauci dice que la vacuna es
positiva yo me la pongo pero si lo dice
el presidente
donald trump no hay una clara diferencia
porque el presidente de unalt ha
denigrado de sus instituciones y de
emigrados científicos no les cree no les
ha creído a lo largo de el manejo de la
pandemia por lo tanto es un claro
espaldarazo west un claro apoyo de lo
que pretenden hacer los demócratas
nosotros somos confiables nosotros somos
seguros porque hacemos caso de las
instituciones que nos han llevado a la
posición que tienen otro elemento que yo
quisiera destacar es el elemento que
destacó la corresponsal y es
empatía hacia el personal sanitario y de
salud no es de extrañar que dentro de
estos 207 mil 211 mil muertos que se
hallaban en muchos también han sido de
esa primera línea de batalla y yo creo
que ese es un elemento que en cualquier
sector sería bien recibido y es que haya
empatía hacia ahora no necesariamente el
ser empático se va a transferir
automáticamente en votos me parece que
fue un error el intento de mike pence de
traer una gripa como la del 2009 a
colación porque no se puede demostrar lo
que él mencionó y es que si yo bailé
hubiera sido presidente en ese momento
el número de muertos hubiera sido
superior a 2 millones es muy difícil de
saber lo que puede ser un error
estratégico y creo que fue un
intercambio de idas y vueltas en los
cuales somos momentos muy positivos para
el vicepresidente tal vez al inicio pero
al mismo tiempo como halagados supo
defenderse en algunos otros espacios
así es profesor gracias y me quedo con
eso que usted dijo de la comparación de
la gripe porcina con este
kobe 19 y ahí me quiero enfocar entonces
con antonio la marte analista política y
directora del centro frotar en américa
en washington dice a antonella la saludó
de nuevo gracias por estar con nosotros
gracias por su tiempo es comparable a
las dos enfermedades es correcto medir
el coach 19 con la gripe porcina además
por supuesto de sus impresiones de este
debate dice presidencial
buenas noches raúl muchas gracias sí yo
creo que no para nada no son dos
cuestiones para nada comparables
principalmente por el impacto que ha
tenido a nivel gubernamental no a nivel
estatista a lo largo de todo el mundo
esta condición de la pandemia del cobi
19 pero claro por supuesto también estoy
de acuerdo con lo que mencionaban
anteriormente las corresponsales tú
también estoy de acuerdo en que este
debate digamos se dio en un tono
bastante más moderado de lo que fue
presidencial no entre donald trump y joe
biden a que el debate bueno fue
claramente un debate bastante vergonzoso
a mi manera de parecer que parecía y se
asemejaba claramente a un circo no al
estilo bastante latinoamericano y con
ciertos comportamientos o mensajes que
no son para nada propios de un
presidente de los eeuu que
constantemente avasallaba interrumpía y
claro por otro lado con un joe biden que
por momentos no se sabía dónde estaba y
él mismo no sabía dónde estaba parado al
menos eso parecía pero a lo que voy es
que estos estos modelos de
comportamiento son muy preocupantes
sobre todo porque ambos candidatos
generan una ola de fanáticos muchas
veces fanáticos extremistas de ambos
lados que siguen el ejemplo de estos
líderes mesiánicos ahora el debate
presidencial dejó mucho de qué hablar
siendo ese auténtico desastre de voces y
de interrupciones ahora creo que esta
noche los candidatos se cuidaron mucho
más aunque bueno por un lado
y mantuvo esos modos de interrumpir
bastante seguido ahora creo que estuvo
mucho más moderado porque era una noche
que no era para arriesgar digamos en
este tipo de debates y
vicepresidenciales hay muy poco que
ganar y mucho que perder en mi
perspectiva de todos modos es
interesante este debate no porque vimos
una pelea prácticamente de dos
candidatos para ver quién resulta va a
ser más estatista y más proteccionista y
muchas mentiras y acusaciones de ambos
lados no además de un doble discurso que
no va de la mano con los hechos quizás
mencionar el ejemplo de kamala harris
cuando mencionó que acabaría con la
criminalización de la marihuana cuando
ella como fiscal encarceló a más de 1500
personas por consumo de marihuana en su
mayoría cabe mencionar afroamericanos y
latinoamericanos y bueno por otra parte
creo que en ese contexto lo que se quiso
se dejaron muchas preguntas sin
responder y este es digamos sólo uno de
los muchos ejemplos que vimos a lo largo
de la noche
así es antonella quiero volver con
rafael piñero si entonces yo le quiero
preguntar al señor viñeros
sobre todo el desempleo que se ha vivido
en eeuu por cuenta de esta pandemia de
joven 19 son más de 30 millones de
empleos también se dejaron como de decir
varias cosas en cuanto a esto en su
opinión que le pareció cómo manejaron
los candidatos el tema del desempleo en
eeuu
como lo mencioné en la primera
intervención yo creo que si la elección
operación enero-febrero hubiera sido un
camino de rosas para presidente de
matrona había confianza en la economía
la economía crecía y el desempleo estaba
más bajo que los últimos 25 años ese
elemento hubiera sido muy positivo había
una cámara fabrice muy nerviosa y
dubitativa en ese tema en particular
pero también es cierto que el
vicepresidente mike pence cometió
algunos errores no es cierto que hoy el
déficit comercial de los eeuu sea más
bajo es más bajo con sida tal vez pero
es el más alto de los últimos 15 años al
mismo tiempo no es completamente cierto
que se hayan recuperado en la mitad de
los empleos que se perdieron la cifra de
desempleo del día viernes de la oficina
de empleo de los estados unidos para que
un 79 por ciento que sigue siendo uno de
los más altos dentro de los países
desarrollados no podemos tomar a españa
o reino unido que tienen tasas cercanas
al 20 por ciento pero si miramos lo que
ha sucedido
en alemania japón o corea del sur nos
vamos a dar cuenta que la situación es
distinta entonces depende con quién se
quieran comparar la administración
encontrará siempre una cifra que puede
que le dé unos resultados menos
negativos pero no deja de ser
preocupante la relación de personas
negras latinas
mujeres que han debido abandonar sus
empleos con la intención de dedicarse al
cuidado de sus hijos o el cuidado de su
hogar y ahí tenemos un segundo tema que
puede ser excesivamente sensible y es el
retorno a los colegios no es cierto
tampoco que el candidatos joe biden esté
completamente de acuerdo con la idea de
mantenerlos cerrados ha dicho en
distintas ocasiones que lo importante es
el bienestar de los pequeños pero que
sin duda alguna también tenemos que
encontrar una manera de hacerlo
relativamente ordenado y relativamente
seguro entonces ahí creo que había otro
elemento a tener en cuenta creo que la
estrategia de mike pence como la hizo él
el debate vicepresidencial hace cuatro
años cuando tenía que enfrentar a tim
kaine fue más o menos la misma técnica
atacar en este caso proponer y en
segundo lugar y en segundo lugar tratar
de defender a su jefe a su widget en
algunos momentos le salió bien y en
algunos otros no lo hizo muy bien yo
creo que el hecho de para muchos empleos
especialmente en el sector de
manufacturas fue significativamente lo
que dijo alrededor de salvar la
industria y de retornar muchos trabajos
que se estaban desarrollando en méxico o
en canadá a los eeuu
eso puede ser significativamente
positivo pero también es cierto que
apela a una técnica y es como antes lo
hicimos bien volvamos a ese sitio seguro
y no necesariamente un economista
medianamente sensato no te voy a decir
que las condiciones sean exactamente
igual el entorno internacional el
entorno nacional interno de los eeuu
cambió el entorno internacional también
hizo lo propio
no es completamente cierto afirmar que
porque lo hicimos bien durante tres años
lo vamos a poder volver a hacer durante
los cuatro siguientes quiero ir ahora a
la capital estadounidense washington 10
y de nuevo con nuestra corresponsal
diana castañeda diana también por
supuesto se habló del tema de los
impuestos del presidente de donald trump
que lo sacó a relucir la candidata a la
vicepresidencia cámara javier dijo que
el presidente pagó 750 dólares en
impuestos también que el presidente debe
4 millones de dólares que no se sabe a
quién y por supuesto la transparencia la
transparencia de los candidatos
kamala harris defendió la transparencia
de joe biden pero no se vio muy decidido
y muy defensor de la transparencia de l
presidente de donald trump es su
candidato
mike pence a la vicepresidencia qué pasa
con esta transparencia de los candidatos
a la presidencia de eeuu y además como
lo ven los estadounidenses
bueno este es un tema muy importante
sobre todo cuando se trata de la
discusión de las elecciones y de la
campaña conmutar a la presidencia de los
eeuu porque es una tradición en este
país que los candidatos revelen con
anticipación su declaración de impuestos
algo que no hizo el presidente de unalt
durante su primera campaña a la
presidencia y ahora este digamos
escándalo sobre la cantidad que pagó el
presidente 750 dólares pues volvió a ser
el tema central que es trato de digamos
responder a este ataque claro de kamala
harris asegurando que el presidente de
unalt song ha generado millones de
trabajos y que ha pagado también
millones en declaración de impuestos
pero esto no ha sido revelado lo
importante ahora también es que la
fiscalía en nueva york está tratando de
que el presidente revele sus
declaraciones de impuestos de los
últimos 10 años así que este será un
tema interesante y por supuesto la
transparencia de los dos candidatos a la
presidencia de los eeuu queda en
cuestionamiento y fue cuestionado por
los dos candidatos
presidencia de los dos partidos hay que
también llamar la atención a que este es
un debate en donde se pudo dar digamos
una discusión de ideas pero no sabemos
si se va a poder repetir lo mismo o por
lo menos esta transparencia en el debate
de ideas en el próximo debate
presidencial ya que todavía no está
confirmado si se va a realizar está
agendado para el 15 de octubre pero la
campaña de bailén ha dicho que no va a
aceptar hacerlo si el presidente
continúa enfermo pero el presidente pues
no ha querido dar mayor información de
su estado de salud recientemente así
decía no hay que esperar a ver entonces
qué ocurre de aquí a la semana que viene
ya cuando estemos cerca de este segundo
y último debate presidencial de cara a
las elecciones del 3 de noviembre quiero
ir ahora con mamen sal a nuestra
corresponsal en la ciudad de nueva york
diana estaba hablando también de el
desempleo en eeuu le pregunto cómo está
el nivel de desempleo en eeuu y además
me quedo con una frase que dijo cámara
sabes qué
afirmó que el candidato a la presidencia
joe biden el candidato demócrata puede
pagar todas las becas todas las deudas
que tienen los estudiantes en la
educación superior es esto posible y
como ese tema en eeuu
sí sí que es verdad que esa frase al
final le va dirigida para un grupo de
votantes por los que han apostado mucho
tanto desde la convención demócrata ya
lo hemos visto el partido y es el voto
de los jóvenes con algo que precisamente
es lo que más ahoga a los jóvenes en
este país es esta deuda estudiantil que
por lo general no terminan de pagar
hasta que hasta que llevan varios años
trabajando entonces es una cosa que
pueden hacer podrían poner encima de la
mesa algunos planes ya lo han hecho pero
sería de difícil sería difícil llevarlo
a cabo porque estamos hablando de
millones y millones de dólares que al
final
tienen que ser revertidos de alguna
manera por otro lado también es
interesante que lo que hemos visto esta
noche ha sido un avance como decía diana
de lo que de lo que podríamos ver en el
siguiente en el debate de la semana que
viene pero sí que es verdad que el tema
principal que era precisamente el
coronavirus y que el partido demócrata
el patio republicano quizá podría
haberse resarcido de toda la negación
que han hecho el coronavirus hemos visto
que la esposa del vicepresidente may
pensó
al escenario sin mascarilla cuando
precisamente los equipos sanitarios se
habían dicho que eran una de las cosas
que se iban a imponer a esta vez y es
que cualquier persona que entrar a la
sala iba a tener que llevar mascarilla
ha sido interesante también ver cómo
kamala harris ha puesto a planes encima
de la mesa con respecto a la economía
con respecto a la policía ha dicho que
va a hacer una reforma total y como
pensé como may pensé que presidente mike
pence al final ha tenido que estar
defendiendo toda la gestión que se ha
hecho hasta ahora atrás han quedado
ataques personales esto me parece
también interesante de resaltar al final
a la candidata kamala harris podría
haber atacado al partido republicano por
las acciones del presidente en las
últimas semanas son las acciones que por
cierto a mike pence tampoco ha comulgado
con ellas completamente ha dicho que los
estadounidenses tienen derecho a conocer
la salud del presidente y precisamente
eso es lo que se nos negó en cuando se
en cuanto se ingresó al presidente de
donald trump y comenzaron las
especulaciones por un lado la
información que llegaba a la casa blanca
y por otro la información que llegaba
equipo médico y dos informaciones que no
tenían nada que ver y luego por otro
lado también ha sido interesante que
kamala harris a no
el vicepresidente may pensé no ha
utilizado a la relación la presunta
relación del hijo de joe biden con el
caso ucrania gate noté algo que sí que
vimos por ejemplo muchos más ataques
personales en el primer debate
presidencial
mamen gracias me quedo en esa misma
ciudad donde se encuentra usted en la
ciudad de nueva york para ir entonces
con antonella y tocar otro de los puntos
importantes en este debate
vicepresidencial el tema de salud la ley
de salud el obamacare que según el
vicepresidente mike pence fue un
desastre en la administración de barack
obama realmente fue un desastre
absolutamente ahora yo creo que fue bien
interesante los distintos tópicos que se
abordaron precisamente en la cuestión de
la salud que es un tema que hoy marca
prácticamente una grieta en la política
norteamericana en temáticas también como
el cambio climático por supuesto el eje
siendo el kobe 19 el manejo de esta
pandemia la economía los acuerdos
comerciales la corte suprema ahora yo
creo que aquí hay que ir a las
propuestas de ambos candidatos no tanto
para el desempleo como bien hablábamos
recién como para cualquier otro aspecto
incluido la cuestión de salud en los
eeuu cuestiones y temas que se han
debatido a lo largo de la noche ahora
cuáles son sus soluciones cuáles son las
soluciones entre comillas digo que han
propuesto ambos candidatos esta noche
más estado todos proponen más estados
los demócratas por un lado buscan subir
aún más los impuestos fomentar el
proteccionismo el nacionalismo económico
y como todo candidato que hemos visto a
lo largo del debate ya sea presidencial
o vicepresidencial la propuesta es
aumentando el gasto público y el tamaño
del estado seguir aumentando la deuda
una deuda que ya supera los 25 millones
de dólares deuda que por cierto tienen
que pagar los ciudadanos para financiar
no hay terminar pagando una deuda
adquirida por políticos irresponsables
ahora abocándonos un poco en el aspecto
de la candidata am la sabes yo creo que
en buena medida lo sabemos bien todo se
está en el ala más radical no de la
izquierda del partido demócrata y ahora
con un joe biden que claramente ha
vivido durante cinco décadas de la
política cinco décadas viviendo de los
impuestos de los ciudadanos
norteamericanos ahora esta noche a
cambio de harris le tocó también
defender no solamente su propio
historial no sino también el de joe by
de mis bien sabemos que la candidata ex
fiscal e integrante del comité judicial
del senado
harris es muy recordada por su
enfrentamiento con by the no durante los
debates en las en las primarias y ahora
le tocó esta noche defender también el
historial de su compañero de fórmula
por ejemplo para
algunos aspectos a colación es que
hablas a gris mientras hacía campaña por
la nominación para aspirar a la
presidencia en 2019 se pronunció a favor
de ponerle fin al embargo económico
contra el régimen comunista de cuba pero
claro las intenciones de jarvis respecto
a cuba evidencian esa continuidad de las
políticas impulsadas por el ex
presidente barack obama quien promovió
desde su comienzo el acercamiento con el
régimen de cuba ahora llevando esto a
otro aspecto incluso hoy en la
administración del presidente de donald
trump lo hemos condenado correctamente
la tiranía venezolana o la tiranía
cubana o la nicaragüense incluso pero
hay una doble moral en raúl hay una
doble moral porque pareciera ser que
busca el visto bueno de las autocracias
y regímenes autoritarios del mundo como
lo son corea del norte con la dinastía
de los qin o como es el caso de rusia y
los atropellos a las libertades que bien
sabemos existen en dicho país ahora para
hacer un cierre digamos donald trump se
termina codeando no con tiranía parece
preferir a los dictadores que a los
aliados democráticos que hay en muchas
partes tiene cierto respeto
y se siente cómodo con líderes
autoritarios como duterte en filipinas
el suicida en egipto y claramente
vladimir putin en rusia
trump pareciera detectar a los tiranos
solamente cuando hablamos de américa
latina y eso debería llamarnos la
atención ahora va enfocando esto en el
aspecto del gasto y volviendo nuevamente
a lo que hablamos recién ya conectó para
hacerte un cierre hay estudios e
instituciones muy respetadas en los eeuu
incluso el instituto manhattan el
manhattan institute en los eeuu que
presentan como las propuestas combinadas
de harris al menos lo que la formula y
ella proponen significaría más de 40
millones de dólares en nuevos gastos
durante una década
digamos esta fórmula lo que busca es
aumentar los impuestos de los ciudadanos
de este país y continuar convirtiendo a
los impuestos en lo que bueno
verdaderamente son una manera de
castigar el éxito o una manera de
saquear y por otro lado y pensando ya en
sus propuestas o políticas camela sabes
ha apoyado repetidamente las estrictas
leyes de control de rentas para imponer
controles de precios en las viviendas
las que claro
toda medida de control de precio termina
provocando el aumento de los precios y
empeora la crisis de la vivienda o del
precio del bien o el servicio al que se
le aplique digamos el control no
funciona el control de precios no
funciona y eso lo podemos contar incluso
desde el caso argentina que somos
expertos en controles de precios o
porque no en venezuela un cubano gracias
a antonella por abrir esa ventana a las
relaciones internacionales de eeuu que
también fue un tema central en este
debate y escuchando a los dos candidatos
surgieron varias dudas quiero ir ahora
con rafael piñeros rafael en la ciudad
de bogotá le preguntó qué tan socialista
puede ser un gobierno en eeuu pueden
llegar a ser a lo mejor como los que
estamos acostumbrados a ver en américa
latina como cuba venezuela nicaragua
porque pues genera miedo en nuestra
audiencia en alguna parte de nuestra
audiencia latinoamericana y por eso le
hago esa pregunta que tan socialista
pueden ser en eeuu y qué tan parecidos
américa latina pueden ser
yo la verdad no creo que haya ninguna
intención tanto en el partido república
en el partido demócrata al menos por
transitar hacia un elemento medianamente
socialista al caso europeo tal vez al
caso de la socialdemocracia yo no lo veo
factible ni en el corto ni en el mediano
plazo lo que pasa es que como usted muy
bien lo dice la retórica es
significativamente útil es
significativamente útil en algunos
estados y en algunos condados pero aún
así no es suficiente para que los
resultados electorales al menos
demuestra de que es efectivo hace
algunas semanas en el 9 los últimos
rally que pude ser el presidente donald
trump en el doral en miami mencionaba a
algún político colombiano de extrema
izquierda si quieres como lo es gustavo
petro pero cuando usted ve en la
votación del año 2016
el condado de el doral o de broward o de
miami dará cuenta de que la ganadora fue
hillary tina entonces démonos cuenta
como este discurso puede tener algunas
fanáticas para el ala más radical de los
cubanoamericanos que se encuentran en
sur de la florida para muchos
venezolanos que han tenido que llegar
debido a las malas políticas
implementadas en los países de américa
latina especialmente en venezuela pero
la verdad yo creo que el sistema
estadounidense y como lo dijera
el padre de la constitución
alexander hamilton yo veo
significativamente difícil que ese tipo
de influencia llegue a tener algún peso
político en los años por venir pero como
le digo retóricamente estimula mostrar
que el ala más de izquierda que es
normal en los partidos que es normal
también en cualquier otro tipo de
agrupación política pues realmente
suceda yo la verdad no lo veo
significativamente posible me satisface
de manera importante el hecho de que de
veras kamala harris defendiéndose en
política exterior no pensé que iba a ser
el lado más más vulnerable pero tuve la
posibilidad de demostrar que también
tienen la posibilidad de tener una hoja
de ruta clara y precisa sobre lo que ha
hecho esta administración porque
algunos analistas en los eeuu afirman
que el problema es la forma pero no el
fondo ponerse más rudo más duro frente
al régimen chino digamos que era
evidente y era necesario tanto en uno
como en otro pero no digamos mentiras
desde hace veinticinco o treinta años
eeuu ha venido incrementando
significativamente sus relaciones con
china ya pesar de que hoy hablemos de un
único fin de una necesidad de o de un
interés por parte de la administración y
que puede que sea un cambio estructural
para las generaciones por venir es decir
depender menos del comercio bilateral
con china digamos que ha sido funcional
en los últimos 30 años tanto para los
republicanos como para los demócratas lo
que pasa es que las críticas que
tradicionalmente se le hacían al régimen
chino alrededor de los derechos humanos
de las libertades individuales no han
sido lo suficientemente fuertes para
producir cambios a nivel interno
la postura del presidente de donald
trump no necesidad de imponer más
canciones o de imponer más impuestos no
necesariamente ha tenido el efecto el
efecto adecuado porque como lo dijeron
tanto uno como el otro en el sector
agrícola hay graves problemas
actualmente porque la producción de los
eeuu principalmente se dirigía hacia la
república popular china
entonces tanto unos como otros se han
beneficiado las empresas que apoyan a
unos y las empresas que apoyan a otros
los celulares las empresas de tecnología
pero también las manufacturas y el
sector agrícola se han visto
significativamente beneficiados por el
aumento creciente del comercio hasta el
año pasado de intercambios entre eeuu y
china
entonces el cambio significativo que
produjo tal vez y que hayan que mirarlo
en retrospectiva tal vez como una
elementos positivos se empezó a
modificar un poco el tipo de relación
pero hasta hoy de eeuu
si siguen siendo importantes aliados
económicos y comerciales se necesita del
entendimiento mutuo no sólo en temas
comerciales sino en cambio climático y
en muchos otros temas de la agenda
internacional no es cierto que no dejen
de hablar no es cierto que no haya que
no dejen de haber negociaciones entre
unos y otros y tal vez yo bayrén que
llegar a ganar se podría beneficiar de
eso de ser un poquito más rudo frente a
la política la república popular china y
sin duda alguna va a ver una presión
importante en el congreso buenos y
también es muy difícil de que donarán
pueda seguir tomando esas medidas
unilaterales por mucho más tiempo porque
eso pasa factura como se le está pasando
en la organización mundial del comercio
en las cuales es la cual reconoció que
muchas de las medidas impuestas frente a
las manufacturas chinas son ilegales y
van en contra del libre mercado profesor
gracias a ustedes ya que estaba hablando
de china quiero hacerle una última
pregunta sobre este tema antonella y
luego pasar al otro tema importante por
supuesto la relación de eeuu rusia
antonella quiero quedarme con la frase y
quede
el candidato my trans dijo que ellos
querían mejorar el campo de juego con
china cómo mejorar este campo de juego y
qué es lo que está fallando
bueno por supuesto hemos escuchado esta
campaña también mike pence decía que
bailén fue el aplaudidor o el porrista
en sus palabras del régimen chino creo
que eso también nos deja mucho que decir
creo que claramente en términos de
relaciones internacionales y de política
exterior en la clave se va a desenlazar
este año en lo que se proceda con chinas
hemos sabido bien que tanto mike pence
como donald trump históricamente han
tenido ciertas discrepancias no en
términos de que tanto que tanta
restricción se imponía a la relación con
china por supuesto una vez ya dentro de
la administración y ahora por supuesto
en campaña ambos van un poco más
acoplados a eso pero vuelvo a insistir
yo creo que hay una gran preocupación no
solamente por este aspecto en términos
de relaciones exteriores y de política
exterior sino también por el desenlace
que estamos viendo hoy en los eeuu otro
ahora el gran
en faro del mundo libre con una
tradición liberal tan significativa tan
inspiradora y hoy preocupa realmente no
la radicalización que podemos ver en
ambos partidos preocupa también el
bipartidismo preocupa el estatismo
dentro de ambas partes ya sea desde el
conservadurismo como dentro de el
socialismo o no las dos caras que hoy se
muestran en los eeuu yo creo que igual
este es un país con la tradición del
fútbol o la tradición del estado de
derecho los check and balances los
límites al poder y como decía thomas
jefferson no el precio de la libertad es
su eterna vigilancia yo creo que por eso
nunca hay que dejar de ponerle el ojo a
los que gobiernan y entender que digamos
ellos trabajan los gobernantes los
presidentes los funcionarios tienen que
trabajar para nosotros nosotros no
tenemos que ser los súbditos o esclavos
de un gobierno no nosotros somos los que
tenemos que generar eso ahora yo creo
que hoy se están pisoteando claramente
los principios de los padres fundadores
al ver cómo ambos candidatos hoy
proponen gastos
y aumento del tamaño del estado con ese
personalismo o mesiánico y olvidando lo
que hizo grande a los eeuu un país que
se inspiró en la revolución gloriosa de
1688 de inglaterra fundamentada en las
ideas de john locke y eso es lo que lo
convierte a los eeuu históricamente en
el faro de la libertad que queda
representado por eso hoy preocupa el
proteccionismo que proponen ambos
candidatos para un país que creció en
base al libre comercio al libre mercado
a la inmigración a la república y al
estado de derecho
antonella sigo con usted para hablar
sobre rusia y luego quiero saber qué
opinión le merece al profesor rafael
citó a kamala harris trump ha
traicionado a los amigos y ha apoyado a
los enemigos refiriéndose a rusia le
quiero preguntar entonces cuál es la
verdadera relación entre la
administración de donald trump con el
presidente vladimir putin que parecen
ser enemigos pero al final si tienen
algo que ver y tiene mucha comunicación
entre ellos absolutamente absolutamente
y eso es un poco lo que conversábamos
hace un rato o raúl fíjate en esto que
mencionábamos como parece ser que para
donald trump
hay ciertas tiranías que se pueden
catalogar como tiranías y otras que no
digamos vemos esa doble moral y yo creo
que en esto al menos en el caso de rusia
y la relación de el presidente donald
trump con vladimir putin es muy claro
como ha cedido también en ciertos
diálogos y en ciertas negociaciones y en
ciertas conexiones no con distintas y
autocracias y dinastías e incluso a lo
largo de del mundo no por supuesto el
lado de rusia es uno para mencionar pero
también volvemos a insistir el caso de
corea del norte digamos hay algunas
tiranías que se condenan como lo es
quizás en américa latina y otras que no
digamos cuáles son los los aspectos que
hay que tener en cuenta ahora yo creo
que acá hay que mostrar digamos la
esencia no tal vez de lo que proponen y
lo que están buscando estos candidatos
hoy vimos en el debate vicepresidencial
por supuesto aún a una personalidad como
como mike pence que representa ese
conservadurismo bastante extremo no es
mike mike pence se describió en su
momento a sí mismo en sus propias
palabras como cristiano conservador y
republicano en ese otro
según él y creo que eso también nos dice
de que va en buena parte esta dura rama
de la derecha conservadora
norteamericana que ya mike pence se ha
manifestado y ha promovido políticas en
contra de aspectos como el aborto o
votando medidas en contra de la
comunidad lgtb y copatrocinando en
aquella enmienda que pretendía prohibir
el matrimonio entre personas del mismo
sexo en el año 2003 este digamos hay
muchos aspectos que digamos que hay que
tener en cuenta se ha solucionar
simplemente escribió en el año 2000
durante su campaña para entrar en el
congreso escribió en su página web que
había que destinar recursos estatales a
las instituciones que daban asistencia a
aquellos que buscaban cambiar su
comportamiento sexual es decir 'vamos no
solamente está a favor de las terapias
de conversión sino que también propone
que se destine dinero público para
financiarlas entonces vemos este
historial conservador en materia también
de de inmigración y de muchos otros
aspectos creo que esos son son temas que
tenemos que poner sobre la mesa también
que los eeuu no necesitan ni mesías ni
populistas ni de izquierdas ni de
derechas y que el mundo libre necesita
precisamente su libertad propiedad
privada mercados
y seguridad jurídica derecho raúl acid
es antonella gracias profesor quiero ir
entonces también para saber qué opinión
le merece lo que dijo cámara sabes en
eso en el debate dijo que tenía
información de que rusia va a volver a
interferir nuevamente en estas
elecciones de 2020 qué tan cierto hay en
esta afirmación que hizo kamala harris
quiero empezar por un elemento más
general para volver a lo que usted
menciona ningún presidente desde el
retorno de la democracia se puede llamar
a rusia en 1991 ha dejado de lado el
tema de ese importante es país la
federación rusa es miembro permanente
del consejo de seguridad de las naciones
unidas con rusia hay temas que no se
pueden dejar de dar
eeuu no le puede dar la espalda a la
federación rusa porque hay armas
nucleares porque está el tema de la
seguridad en europa y de la relación con
la organización del tratado del
atlántico norte porque hay una estrecha
cooperación en materia científica
especialmente en materia espacial porque
la situación en ucrania genera en 2014
hace que los eeuu no se pueda permitir
el lujo de que incremente la influencia
militar de rusia en los asuntos europeos
en los asuntos del mediterráneo
ninguna otra de las distintas esferas
estratégicas en las cuales tiene
fronteras desde esa perspectiva y como
lo dijera alexander hamilton nuevamente
vuelvo al ejemplo no hay peor problema
para una joven república que la
influencia externa porque la influencia
externa divide y en eso ni los
republicanos y los demócratas han sabido
cómo mantener a raya a la federación
rusa hace cuatro años fue evidente
rusia simplemente utilizó las redes
sociales para llevar un mensaje
extremismo extremista en todas las
posiciones en alguna escaló más y en
algunas caló menos pero el resultado al
final fue lo que se temía por parte de
los padres fundadores como lo mencionaba
a mí y contertulia acerca de la
influencia externa que si puede volver a
pasar por supuesto que sí por supuesto
que puede volver a pasar de hecho tanto
el efecto
efe como la cia han alertado sobre esa
situación y hay una profunda
preocupación tanto como para
desestabilizar las elecciones y me niego
a creer que el sistema político de una
gran nación como los eeuu sea tan
excesivamente vulnerable para ello pero
que la influencia la influencia de las
redes sociales hoy no se puede dejar de
lado la compra de advertainment radical
y la compra de propaganda a través de
internet es significativamente barata es
significativamente fácil de realizar y
por lo tanto puede haber una manera de
influyan en ese sentido
la situación que une o que relaciona a
los eeuu con rusia no se va a terminar
de un día para el otro
tienen que seguir dialogando con los
agravantes y es que un solo presidente
de rusia vladimir putin llegó en el año
2000 por primera vez al poder ha tenido
relación con cuatro distintos y
eventualmente con un quinto si hay un
cambio en la administración el 3 de
noviembre de tal forma que el problema
no es si hay más o menos influencia de
rusia el problema no es si rusia
determina las elecciones en los eeuu
yo lo veo bastante improbable sino que
se tiene que establecer algún tipo de
relación porque los temas son variados
porque la agenda es dinámica y porque
son grandes potencias que no se pueden
dar la espalda unos a otros
un ejemplo en particular en oriente
medio la situación en libia
otro ejemplo el enriquecimiento de
uranio
otro ejemplo la reducción de armas de
destrucción masiva que cada uno es el
mayor en
el tenedor de este tipo de armamento
gracias profesor quiero ir ahora con
nuestra corresponsal en la ciudad de
nueva york que mamen sala mamen y ya
para ir finalizando y haciendo nuestras
conclusiones hablemos de un tema también
de la corte suprema de eeuu que fue
principal en este debate con la
nominación de la fuerza amy con iba a
ver el vicepresidente my friends pidió
una audiencia justa y pidió respeto por
el otro lado kamala harris dijo que a 27
días de estas elecciones ellos tienen
derecho a que no se nombre y que se
espere para que cuando eeuu en un nuevo
presidente es el nuevo presidente nómina
a quien considere que puede reemplazar a
arbey y que murió recientemente mamen
pero también hay un tema importante y es
el pacto word que dicen a los
republicanos y también dijo el
presidente el vicepresidente mike pence
que es que acusa a los demócratas que
quieren hacer una cantidad de reformas a
la justicia de eeuu y a las leyes de
eeuu para que así ellos puedan tener más
es representantes en la corte suprema
que es el pack de core que tan de cierto
hay en esto y cómo vamos a entonces a
ver la audiencia de mí con iba a ver la
semana que viene en el senado
si ahora en este tema también se han
quedado muchas preguntas sin responder
cabal a harris al igual que lo hizo el
candidato demócrata joe biden en el
primer debate presidencial no ha
especificado cómo actuarán ellos en caso
de que a la señora barrer llegue a la
corte suprema así que de nuevo vuelve a
estar esa imagen es que se ha hecho esa
resolución en el aire eso sí mike pence
ha dicho que él es un pro life es una
probidad kamala harris ha querido dejar
claro que tanto ella como bailén también
son católicos y que defienden a la vida
pero no han dicho muy claramente
exactamente qué es lo que van a hacer en
caso de que esta candidata llegue a la
corte suprema
gracias mamen quiero ir ahora con
nuestra corresponsal en washington de la
capital estadounidense diana castañeda
diana y le quiero preguntar entonces que
podemos ver en el próximo debate
presidencial la semana que me dicen que
no tenemos que no tenemos a diana
castañeda en la ciudad de washington
mami mamen sigo con usted le quiero
preguntar entonces que podemos ver en el
segundo de los tres debates
presidenciales que vamos a ver el 15 de
este mes
sí pues lo primero que tendremos que ver
raúl es si realmente vamos a ver ese
debate porque como saben a raíz de que
el presidente de donald trump haya sido
contagiado por coronavirus las dudas y
las cuestiones en torno a si ese debate
se va a celebrar o no pues han comenzado
por un lado el equipo de don al drama
asegura que ellos quieren seguir
adelante con ese debate la campaña de
joe biden dice que lo harán siempre y
cuando los expertos sanitarios
los sanitarios consideren que es seguro
debemos recordar que ese segundo debate
presidencial que se espera que se
celebre el 15 de octubre en la ciudad de
miami en florida tendrá lugar a 14 días
después de que hayamos conocido a que
donald trama ha sido contagiado de kobe
19 eso sí si realmente se lleva a cabo
las medidas van a ser mucho más extremas
y entonces sí que será importante que
los equipos sanitarios lleven a cabo esa
promesa que hicieron en este debate
vicepresidencial y que al final parece
que no se ha cumplido y es que todo el
mundo que esté
debería utilizar una mascarilla y hoy lo
hemos visto en en el marido de la
cantidad la cámara harris pero no le
hemos visto por ejemplo en la mujer del
vicepresidente mike pence mamen gracias
ahora sí ya tenemos a nuestra
corresponsal en washington dc y diana
castañeda diana black live mar y todo lo
que tiene que ver con el cambio
climático que rescatamos entonces de lo
que vimos en este debate
vicepresidencial
bueno digamos que una de las preguntas
importantes de este debate se centró en
la opinión sobre el caso de brianna
taylor que es un ejemplo de este debate
de justicia racial en la nación en donde
kamala harris respondió que él merece
justicia que debe ser atendido como tal
y este es el caso de una joven que murió
abaleado en su casa cuando la policía
estaba haciendo un operativo y abrió
fuego en contra de el novio de esta
mujer quien pierde la vida pero por su
parte mike pence aseguró que confía en
la justicia y que confía en los
departamentos de policía y esto pues da
un ejemplo de esa discusión nacional que
están abordando ya de cabeza las
elecciones los dos candidatos a la
vicepresidencia y a la presidencia y es
que del lado del partido demócrata se
habla y se busca de mayor justicia
racial de una reforma a los sistemas y a
los departamentos de policía en donde se
aumenten los jueces para que se puedan
llevar antes
las cortes de estos casos de injusticia
por parte de la policía donde también
por parte de recursos federales se
destinen a este tipo de entrenamientos
más especializados en cómo actuar por
parte de la policía y del lado
republicano se habla de una reforma pero
para que se contraten más agentes de
policía para que también los policías
cuenten con ese respaldo de la comunidad
así que esto es un debate nacional que
vimos reflejado en esta digamos este
encuentro de ideas entre los dos
candidatos a la vicepresidencia pero hay
otro tema que también será importante de
aquí al próximo debate de los candidatos
presidenciales y será conocer qué
medidas más puede tomar la
administración del presidente
donald trump y los gobernadores en los
estados que son republicanos para tratar
de facilitar o obstaculizar el acceso al
voto de los estadounidenses
diana mamen les quiero agradecer como
siempre un placer poder compartir con
ustedes en estas coberturas especiales
con todo lo que tiene que ver con la
política estadounidense en este caso las
elecciones presidenciales nada menos que
eso muchísimas gracias quiero volver con
mi invitado rafael rafael la conclusión
del debate de esta noche también quiero
saber qué opinión le merece entonces de
todo esto que tiene que ver con la
justicia racial en eeuu y el cambio
climático que no quiero que se me queden
por afuera antes de terminar el programa
y profundos cuestionamientos
confrontaciones no se dejaron de
observar sin duda alguna fue un debate
más civilizado pero no dejaron de lado
los constantes ataques entre lo que
propone uno y lo que propone otro ese es
el sistema político y esas son las
reglas de juego creo que un momentos
fuertes para él
actual vicepresidente de los eeuu
especialmente cuando desnudo la falta de
preparación de una propuesta para
reformar la policía de una manera clara
por parte de los demócratas no la tienen
clara y fue un error de el candidato yo
va a ir en proponer pero también hubo
elementos fuertes de la candidata a
vicepresidenta kamala harris en el
sentido de desnudar la incapacidad el
descontrol que aún reside en la casa
blanca que no puede con y que no puede
controlar ni siquiera los elementos de
seguridad en materia de cambio climático
en particular de fuerte
la senadora kamala harris y
eventualmente con una propuesta
alrededor de energías renovables eso
indica un cambio significativo con lo
que se ha venido y hay un tire y afloje
supera mente interesante sobre el
plástico me quisiera quedar aquí un
momento la semana anterior el
vicepresidente el candidato joe biden
logró un importante apoyo de un
sindicato de la industria petrolífera en
pensilvania asegurándose que no iba a
prohibir el fáctica lo que he dicho es
hagamos lo mejor ese es el elemento
importante yo voy a ir siempre a tomar
una línea del centro y al final de su
intervención trató de dejarlo en claro
kamala harris joe biden ha demostrado a
lo largo de su vida política que puede
ser un candidato bipartidista
antonella a sus conclusiones de este
debate vicepresidencial
bueno raúl al menos esperemos que en los
próximos debates presidenciales imperen
debates reales y no peleas entre
fanatismos o personalismos tal vez
copiando un poco la cordialidad al menos
la moderación que existió en el debate
de hoy esperemos que se hablen de
cuestiones que que urgen no en términos
de problemas internos y sociales desde
el país aspectos que giran en torno al
racismo a libertades individuales y
sobre todo las realidades de política
exterior y y propuestas económicas
concisas yo creo que acá cerrando
haciendo un paneo de estos dos
personajes en estos aspectos que
mencionábamos recién por parte del
presidente donald trump a ver es
realmente preocupante en los términos de
migración los términos migratorios como
tratan los latinoamericanos y
principalmente a los mexicanos no como
si fueran lo peor del hemisferio
recordemos en sus propias palabras
cuando dijo que méxico manda gente a
eeuu y que no mandan a los mejores no
sino que mandan a gente con un montón de
problemas y bueno esas fueron las
palabras del presidente de trump este
pero bueno yo creo y espero que en los
próximos debates veamos algo un poco más
cordial donde no se atropellan entre los
dos candidatos
este y espero que se pueda dar en buenos
términos
así es antonella creo que lo esperamos
todos muchísimas gracias por su tiempo
también a rafael gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí en france 24 que tengan
ustedes uno feliz resto de noche y
ustedes también por por supuesto
acompañarnos o como siempre en todas
nuestras emisiones especiales aquí en
france 24 buena noche